tonnes l'église catholique a fermement
condamné le vote des députés espagnol
aujourd'hui comme d'ailleurs les
représentants des religions protestante
orthodoxe et juive
l'espagne est devenue le premier pays
d'europe à autoriser en même temps que
le mariage l'adoption pour les
homosexuels
c'était une promesse du nouveau premier
ministre procès luis zapatero valérie
fournier un tournant historique dans
l'histoire de la société espagnole par
183 voix contre 136 et 6 abstentions les
députés ont voté aujourd'hui un projet
de loi autorisant non seulement le
mariage homosexuel mais également
l'adoption par les couples homosexuels
à la grande satisfaction des
associations une première dans un pays
aussi profondément catholique
c'est un moment historique pour nous qui
pendant tant d'années dans ce pays
nous n'avons pas été considérés et là
nous ressentons vraiment une grande joie
et comédienne valeria jusqu'à présent le
mariage était possible seulement aux
pays bas et en belgique
partout ailleurs en europe il n'est pas
reconnu par exemple aux pays bas cela
fait maintenant cinq ans que ces
cérémonies civiles sont légales ailleurs
un certain nombre de grands pays
européens comme l'allemagne ou les pays
scandinaves
à défaut de mariage propose des statuts
dérogatoires chez nous le pacs existe
depuis plus de cinq ans quant au mariage
celui célébré à bègles le 5 juin 2004 a
été cassé par les différences ou mousse
hésite
un jugement confirmé hier par le conseil
d'état voilà en ce qui concerne
l'adoption il s'agit donc du premier
pays d'europe à la légaliser pour les
couples homosexuels